dangerous fast-moving wildfire is
slowing down this morning
south of los angeles the bond fire
nearly quadrupled in size in just a few
hours yesterday
pushed by powerful winds officials say
it started as a house fire
it has burned at least 6 400 acres and
is just
10 percent contained but some areas that
were evacuated
are now allowing homeowners to return
jonathan bigliotti has more on this
california wildfire season
that just won't end
wind gusts reaching 70 miles an hour
continue to drive this fire near
neighborhoods in the canyons of orange
county
the wind was howling bruce mcdougall
captured these images of flames that
engulfed his neighborhood
and destroyed his truck the firemen were
here and they
foamed the back of my house and i think
that saved it
bone dry conditions gave the blaze
plenty of fuel to grow
this is the second major wildfire to hit
this area in the past two months
it kind of felt like you were safe for
at least a couple years from
the brush that the fire had already come
through about two months ago
there are 500 firefighters from more
than 30 different agencies battling the
blaze
on thursday two of them were injured and
taken to a hospital but their conditions
this morning
are unknown this fire is driven by dry
vegetation and high winds we're talking
about gusts up to 70 miles per hour you
can see
firefighters here on the ground trying
to stop this blaze from spreading
you have a concern that maybe the fire
is a little too close that's enough
that's enough to have your belongings
prepared and to evacuate
because of covid officials aren't
providing shelters for evacuees
instead they're encouraging them to seek
private safety with
family or friends or go to a hotel
local utilities cut power to 52 thousand
residents
starting on wednesday and more than 32
thousand
remain in the dark thursday but even
that precaution
wasn't enough to prevent images like
this which had become sadly too familiar
to the people
of california a record-breaking 4
million acres have burned across the
state
so far this year the wind has calmed
down and so too have the flames
intense enough to melt this truck the
red flag warnings remain in effect
through saturday back to you
all right jonathan every year it seems
we're telling the story and every year
it's just as devastating i
can't imagine what it's like for people
who are seeing it last year thinking god
i hope that doesn't happen to me
they're on the news and this you've got
the complication that it's very
difficult to go anywhere because of
covid
yeah well it's not only the same every
year he's saying it's a record year and
you know the president was saying it's
it's forest management issues but
the officials in california are saying
actually it's climate change yeah they
didn't appreciate that
yeah they did not appreciate that at all
all right thank you jonathan